nous sommes gare du nord à paris le 1er
mars 2017 vers 20 heures une vingtaine
d'élèves reviennent d'un court séjour
pédagogique à bruxelles en descendant du
thalys trois d'entre eux sont
appréhendés par les forces de l'ordre
pour un contrôle d'identité
au menu palpation tutoiement et
fouillent des valises sous le regard des
passants et suite à ce contrôle qui les
ont jugé humiliant et discriminatoire il
décide de porter plainte contre l'état
déboutée en première instance en 2018
ils ont obtenu gain de cause ce mardi
devant la cour d'appel de la capitale
les caractéristiques physiques des
personnes contrôlées notamment leur
origine leur âge et leur sexe ont été la
cause réelle du contrôle et met en
évidence une différence de traitement
laissant présumer l'existence d'une
discrimination
le contrôle d'identité est jugée
discriminatoire et constitue une faute
lourde de l'état
verdict l'état est condamné à verser
1500 euros en réparation du préjudice
moral subi
à chacune des trois victimes de ce
contrôle au faciès alors si cette
affaire est intéressante c'est notamment
parce que pour caractériser l'aspect
discriminatoire du contrôle la haute
juridiction âge site jauger
l'échantillon contrôlé non pas par
rapport à l'effectif de la classe
entière composée exclusivement d'élèves
issus de minorités visibles mais par
rapport à l'ensemble de la population
qui descendant du train se trouvait sur
le quai et n'a pas été contrôlé ce
faisant la cour constate ce que
plusieurs études ont déjà démontré à
savoir une sur représentation des
personnes issues de minorités visibles
parmi les individus concernés par les
contrôles de police
en 2012 une étude publiée dans la revue
scientifique population c'est justement
intéressé aux contrôles réalisés en gare
du nord est compris et cela tombe bien
au niveau des thalys et le constat est
édifiant
les personnes blanches ils représentent
86% des voyageurs mais seulement la
moitié des personnes contrôlées tandis
que les personnes noires représente 7%
de celles et ceux qui transitent pour
23% de ses contrôles à âge sexe et
encombrement égal c'est à dire si la
personne a un bagage ou non une personne
noire à près de cinq fois plus de
chances d'être contrôlé qu'un blanc au
niveau des quêtes des listes de la gare
du nord et la tendance est similaire au
niveau national un rapport du défenseur
des droits publié en 2017 concluait qu'a
lieu de
si dans ce niveau de diplôme et
situation financière égale les jeunes
sommes perçues comme arabes ou noirs
avaient une probabilité 20 fois plus
élevé que les autres de subir un
contrôle des forces de l'ordre